those switch gears we are heading into
the fourth of july weekend of course and
to celebrate this week this morning
rather we're highlighting some of the
best barbecue spots around town that's
right it is all barbecue all day ron
fuchal joining us from big b's texas
barbecue in the southwest valley oh ron
what you got there
oh yes
all sorts of fun stuff good looking
potato salad here i'm going to try some
in a little bit we're big bees and we
got big b with us right here brian what
do we have here in the smoker all ready
to go this independence day tri-tip
there on the top we have some beef ribs
and we turn it we got some briskets
working
uh
those are all brisket there you go
yeah we still have uh a good six hours
on most of these meats the beef ribs
will be coming out about nine and then
as it rotates around you'll see some
baby back ribs and just get ready for
lunch all right this is in the southwest
part of the valley
near patrick and fort apache here's
where you're at okay what makes texas
barbecue the best i mean i
i won't say it's the best i'll say what
we do that make us unique i i bring my
wood in from texas uh i only burn
mesquite from the rio grande valley
and that's the biggest flavor profile
that makes texas texas so there's a few
other words you use but can't get them
here locally okay we got some over here
we're gonna nelson is is chopping up
some tri-tip here what do we have here
nelson you got the good-looking tri-tip
just off of just off the smoker yep uh
we got some charging going on here it's
nice and juicy as you guys see
fresh from the smokers i gotta try a
piece of this is that okay yeah what
flavor is the triathlon the tri-tips are
different flavors aren't there is this
just triton
is it is it try different rob you know
all right there we go
try bite of this
much good taste and try to
talking with my mouth full
sorry
but no we're big bees and this is a fun
place to uh let's go back and grab brian
again real quick can we chat um brian
we're ready for some texas barbie are
you expecting big crowds this weekend
with the uh independence day definitely
one of our busiest weekends of the year
for sure so this is this is father's day
and this is our two busiest days in new
york show i have a traeger in the
backyard with the smoker pellet is that
wrong i mean you use real wood real
smoke but it's cheating we're we're in
the desert so you can't you got to do
what you got to do man i mean that's uh
i don't personally use the the pellets
but if that's what we got to do to get a
barbecue on and it's about the barbecue
okay i'm learning how to do some
barbecue here this weekend we got a lot
of stuff here you got coleslaw baked
beans the full treatment out here at big
bees is this your only location right
now are you getting a couple we have to
have one on henderson on sailrite's
parkway in eastern and uh your barbecue
is low and slow 12 14 hours on a brisket
if you don't feel like doing it we got
you coming down do you smoke it out
there fresh as well yes yes every day
things go on
all right all hickory is smoking right
there
and ready to go here as we get ready for
independent happy independence day
everybody
out there certainly celebrate america
american history nothing says america
like good barbecue nothing says america
like good texas barbecue
as well so we're at that big beast oh i
got to bring some food back to the
station do you have any that i can take
back
are they they're pretty hungry back
there that's all right we'll make sure
and feed them yeah can't have uh all
this food on camera and not uh not in
the mouth no we're drooling here
did i leave anybody out that needs food
back at the station that i gotta take to
um we'll have it well plenty for
everybody how's that sounds good happy
independence day everybody yeah and to
you as well ron and to and to everyone
that uh you've been stopping by this
morning
low and slow good advice yeah i'm just
gonna buy it for life for life in
general low and slow
how to go through things